نتابع معكم ما هذه الصور المباشره من اضنه
التركيه حيث هذا المنزل وما زال عمال
الانقاذ يحاولون اسعاف من بقي على قيد
الحياه تحت هذه الانقاذ نذكر بان العدد
عدد القتلى في
هذه
الاحداث او هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
بلغ
1498 قتيلا حتى الان
وسبعه الاف وستمائه واربعين
جريحا او اصابه في تركيا جراء هذا الزلزال
الذي ضرب اليوم الاراضي التركيه وضرب ايضا
الشمال السوري الارقام غير واضحه في سوريا
ولكن المرصد السوري وفق المرصد السوري قال
بان عدد القتلى وصل الى 900 قتيل مازلنا
نحاول الوصول الى اخر الانباء والتطورات
سواء في تركيا او حتى في سوريا الوضع في
سوريا
بالتاكيد غامض وليس واضحا سواء في المناطق
التي يسيطر عليها النظام السوري او حتى
تلك المناطق التي يسيطر عليها او تسيطر
عليها المعارضه